crazy recently do good I'm so bummed I
haven't played yet because it was like
two minutes after we started playing
with our jaws or just on the desk like
what the hell they done in a good way
yeah I think I haven't gotten to play
yet I was in the East Coast all last
week when I came out and kind of its
extreme man they they know their game
they know what they're doing so I onyx
is they just listen I feel like in so
many times so just touching back on
their last one right was hoops which was
cool fun idea changes the game cuz you
know you know you're doing aerials and
all this stuff neo tokyo to be fair
that's a that would be another example
of what i'm getting at is okay the
essence of rocket league that I think
where people kind of like eventually
step away from these new updates is that
you can't change the core game you can't
change the maps specifically because
that is part of the court game is riding
up walls and knowing where to be for
aerials and says like that you know
changing the ball physics you can't do
that this game keeps all that intact but
just adds like a powerup ability right
you can teleport or another player is
you can use a plunger to grab the ball
you can use a harpoon to bring yourself
towards the ball you can attach spikes
to your car so you can stick to the ball
you can create a tornado effect that
throws cars in your way like off their
path you can shoot another opponent
right which which basically it's like
cutting the brakes and throwing it into
noss die just like you get you them and
like they're spinning out of control um
it's real fun and I I played that the
most over the weekend I could not stop
playing that mode um it's really fun and
I think in a very good way it like
preserves rocket League like you know
cuz you start off the game it's it you
know these modes or these abilities
coming to say I thought it was a punch
the ball difficult that's so that's the
haymaker and that and the spikes are
like the ones you want to hold on to and
wait for the moments let me ask you this
did if you don't use it do you lose it
we know you you don't lose it but you
lose the opportunity to get another
ability sure so certain ones you want to
get rid of you can still hold on to it
Oh
exactly so the haymaker in the spikes
you want to hold on to that because
that's your main offensive push freeze
until the air as well um well Oh in the
twitch as just asking for the power to
just puncture the ball and then the game
it's like I what the sandlot say it's
like a idiot now we can't play no more
yeah it's a really fun game i think uh
yeah I mean I'm super into it and it you
know eventually yell doesn't say is you
know these things come in 10 second
cooldown so you're still playing rocket
League in moments right the game or
around or a goal will happen it's rocket
League for 10 seconds and every 10
seconds thereafter like you're still
using your your skills for the game and
nothing's changed other than now you're
learning and trying new things look like
all right now I gotta like you spikes in
a manner where I'm gonna aerial up and
attach to in midair and just like have
hands on my car and just run this thing
the goal drive it up the wall hold on to
it and see if anyone can catch you what
you talked about in terms of that flow
is like super apparent because like yeah
for that moment we're like no one's
using a power up and you're going to
score a goal and you're like all right
easy I got this it's like everyone
activates their powers at once it seems
like and then suddenly the ball is
pulled to the other end of the map then
it's frozen in midair and then just like
all those other powers come into play
it's it's super interesting and I think
you know like a lot of people were
worried that doing stuff like this would
impact the core gameplay but like you
said they found a really good balance
yeah I think so and you know those
rocket lab maps were the change to map
it everything I think you know I'm sure
there are people who get a kick out of
that stuff but as far as like general
consensus I feel like like around the
office and like even honors yes vs. nice
to try some different but you just want
to preserve that that feeling we all had
for like the first and you know initial
months of that game where it was like I
just want to get good at this and you
know you're still everyone's still
striving to get better at that core game
right um so this is I think I think this
is actually like the perfect way to like
let off some steam if you're having that
you're having a bunch of you set a six
day with your spikes I know well that's
what I think is always appealing because
for as unpredictable as it could be its
mechanics for predictable so you get
really good and master this game whereas
this seems like it's doing the opposite
it's just throwing these wrenches into
the cogs and I'm wondering it didn't
initially sound appealing to me but it's
like watching game plow he looks really
fun but I'm wondering if it's kind of
the the system they're still in place
for it to be something you can master
rather than have these cool power-ups
actually just disrupting the entire
formula i think it was back and forth i
think because these power-ups happen
randomly that if you know you are
skilled and you're learning you're
you're doing whatever you are and you
have mastered spikes someone can still
pull you out of it and that's both the
skill of that player and it's also just
luck and this is the luck of the
situation of the game so as long as you
can embrace that and just be okay with
letting you know someone just school you
with one of these spikes or any maker
then you're having a good time and again
I think it's like a nice balance with
the actual game because let's get real
like you know you do to be tues online
competitive and you're gonna have what
five streaks of just losing like yeah I
don't know I I think it's a nice
changeup it's like REI steel like what
do you think my life yeah it's an
excellent option yeah yes so another
thing with the update is this you said
you're finding on reddit like haha this
trading system which is becoming almost
like a seedy underbelly almost of the
rocket League community which obviously
I'm not speaking ill of rocket League
but you were saying you were looking
through red and kind of digging through
like neogaf forums about how people are
kind of selling these crazy crates for
like 90 real-world dollars now Yashin
keys bro yeah yeah that's the well 90
real-world dollars translates into keys
right no let me preface this office so
they've entered a they've introduced
they've introduced crates and keys
crates are obtainable I would say
roughly around you know maybe a dozen
matches or so you can get a random crate
drop different system compared to the
items that are introduced as a game
that's completely separate so you get
random create drop great what's inside
it about a dozen exclusive there are two
different types you get Champions one
champion to each has like at a bunch of
wide range of different rarity items
including like to import cars that are
like unique you know Dominus
variance in stuff like that they're all
of it looks so good it's all like really
exclusive cool items however in order to
open that crate you need to buy keys and
there is no other way you can get keys
other than trading with other people but
you're more inclined to open these
things up at least one or two I don't
know keys are a dollar fifty each or
twenty four twenty so you open it up and
it's a random luck of the draw whatever
is in that crate you can potentially get
so you I lucked out on my second when I
opened eye open for and I'm not going to
open anymore ever again who knows but
anyways I open one and I got that Takumi
rxt rare model and it's Dolby I saw that
you tweeted the other night I green dude
it's kind of like a clear hide you can
see the engine sounds awesome oh man so
this is where I'm already getting like
conflicted and frustrated because I
really want this however that there are
things you can do in this game to avoid
person keys this is where it gets this
is where it's like oh my god what
happened rocket League um we can like
the Oosterhouse from diablo 3 first
thing you can do if you don't like the
system at all as you can turn off
entirely so you cannot see it visually
in the game which is nice so you don't
see the by keys often you know we're
talking with halo earlier like hmm I
don't want to see that it's not just
shoved down your throat right which is
great too I can basically never open a
great get five crates either turn it
turn them trade them into the game and
get a random piece of loot back or item
back that's above higher rarity so that
could be a one these new like animated
skins that are really cool looking or
here's the real kicker is or I could hit
the web and go to of course subreddit
rocket League exchange and already you
see it and there's this is auctions so
people who have unlocked a crate and
have gone like the Dominus GT it's a
legit car people want that a lot he goes
oh start firstly this one guy first he
links to like an auction song in this
description i read it is they all start
the bid at 30 keys and then you see gold
down 60 90 some guys paying nine
keys which is give or take $80 so that's
the currency now is it rocket League
keys and so you can dupe later trailer
item trading you can do keys which is
the currency or yeah you know it's like
you see other people or the other way
you can do it as you see people go like
I have these rims which is actually when
I was thinking of he's like I got these
rims and that's what he sold rims for
eighty dollars oriini I'm looking for
this you see like want this looking for
this what was the base game fifteen
dollars your 20 Oh point 20 yeah sure
point being you're paying like quadruple
for rims than you paid for the actual
game that they're set in that's nuts
there are people there enthusiasts that
like rocket League including us but I
don't think I would do that I definitely
wouldn't buy rims for that but your car
is pretty sick i'll give you like i'll
buy lunch tomorrow for that but i'm done
but i'm done i like i'll give it to me
this is I mean I felt that I felt that
addiction I mean it was like I gotta
open another one I did [ __ ] item next
one cone yeah practically and next one
is the same I was like I'm done and I so
I turned it off but pretty sure the
point being is like maybe in a month or
so I could do it uncheck that option and
see how many crates I have which I could
flip out yeah cuz the recipe of
overwatch except over watches like you
see how much you're getting a pretty
standard experience amount each match
like obviously do better you'll get a
little more but depending on what metals
you get but then you open the crates
with the currency whereas rocket League
sounds more like it's very very rare to
get a crate at much like you said your
kind of falling through the ranks on
purpose to rise through them and get
those streaks and the lower ranks which
psionics said they're gonna start
banning people who are manipulating this
is right that's the really weird thing
is you got people intentionally quitting
games in order to get yet the me you say
in order to get that nerve because I
guess that's kind of a I mean I guess
it's not confirmed but it's a mechanical
that of that great drop is how many wins
you have in a row so yeah that's
interesting but I don't know I'm still a
huge fan of the game I think it's a
weird move but i also think opting out
of that this is like no harm no foul
right like the game is still fun it's
just cosmetics yeah i'm still having a
blast with it i know him you guys are
too yeah i'm hoping to get in this after
and I still have not played it but
anyway so yeah that's a rumble mode and
rocket leads newest update along with
the trading system and whatnot which is
kind of becoming a little Shady in a
little areas but anyway let me know what
the craziest thing you've done in rocket
league's new update in the comments
below because I have not seen half the
stuff I saw like spike saves and
haymaker shots anyway